[Music]
we are striving to forge our union
with purpose to compose a country
committed
to all cultures colors characters
and conditions of man and so we listen
if you don't know now you know that is
inauguration breakout star and youth
poet laureate amanda gorman now she's
getting ready to perform
at the super bowl pre-show where she
will pay tribute to three remarkable
americans
who will be honored at the game for
helping their communities navigate the
very difficult past year
first on cbs this morning we're
revealing the nfl's honorary captains
for the super bowl 55 coin toss suzy
dorner
is a nurse manager at tampa general
hospital in florida
tremaine davis is a los angeles educator
and
james martin is a veteran from
pittsburgh and manuel bajorka spoke with
all three
ahead of the big game president bush
would you please toss the coin
it's an honor an appreciation reserved
for some of america's
modern heroes reverend dr king you do
the honors
i'm still very surprised i'm probably
going to be at the super bowl like this
is not happening
tremaine davis susie dorner and james
martin all met for the first time on
this zoom call
and in less than two weeks the three
will be on the field in tampa
honored for their dedication to
community during the pandemic
i'm still waiting for the psych yes i'm
still waiting for the site
at a time when so many are feeling
isolated marine corps veteran james
martin has kept his focus
on staying connected martin a father of
three
is streaming high school sports in his
pittsburgh pennsylvania suburb free to
the community
she needs a reason to smile connecting
fellow veterans through gaming as part
of the wounded warrior project
and opening his home to neighborhood
kids facing domestic issues
you know hats off to my wife knowing
full and well that that was going to
cost our grocery bill
astonishingly my daughter switched out
her bedroom
to give the boys the bigger room our
laundry machine has not
stopped but if it's not for the village
how how else do we grow my dad kept on
saying
is this is it april 1st today is this
april fool's day and i'm like no no this
is real
it's physically and emotionally
exhausting susie dorner is a registered
nurse
managing the covet intensive care unit
at tampa general hospital
in florida there's been a personal toll
for you as well
during the pandemic i lost both my
grandmothers and i was
unable to be there with them as they
passed away
one of my grandmothers she was actually
a nurse in world war
ii and she would always tell me stories
about what it was like to be a nurse
caring for
our soldiers she was a very big
inspiration in my life
the work that we do at ucla is a high
focus on first generation college-going
students
and also students of color i'm hoping
that you will have more
tremaine davis has worked in higher
education his entire career
now at ucla providing mentorship and
opportunity to the underserved
he's been a beacon for his students
during the pandemics securing laptops
and tablets for remote learning
internet access and mental health
support all while supporting his family
at home i'm going to use this to make
sure that i represent for those of
all of us that you know work in these
spaces to be that example of that we
we do amazing work day in and day out
and if there's
one thing that i can be thankful for in
regards to the pandemic is the fact that
we got a chance to showcase that
it seems like for all of you the
question that drives you is what can i
do to help
the commonality of all of us is that
we're in a position of stewardship
um we're in a position to serve others
it's because of
you a nurse that put her head down and
said
every day no matter what the
circumstances of going to work
and i'm going to do my best to save
people or a t-shirt that says the world
is about to shut down
on these kids so when everybody does the
work
we can all do better
they are each so worthy of this honor
now on top of the honorary captain's
announcement the nfl has also revealed
that it will invite about 7 500
vaccinated health care workers from
tampa
and the surrounding central florida area
to attend
the super bowl and that all 32 nfl teams
across the country
will be able to invite health care
workers from their communities
to attend the big game tony
just exemplary individuals manny thank
you very much
vlad michelle i don't know what's better
if you're those three being the honorary
captain and being on the field of the
super bowl
or having a poem from amanda gorman
written in your honor
yeah that is pretty cool to me it just
signifies a veteran
an educator and a medical professional
sort of the bedrock of our society
salute them not just this year but like
every year yeah and add to that the fact
that there will be an
audience there will be fans
participating in that game i know
the players are going to be really
excited about that can't wait can't wait